well wedding season is upon us and it's
always hard to find a unique wedding
present I go with the toaster because it
seems like everybody needs a toaster but
we decided to team up with Etsy to help
you give the perfect personalized gift
[Music]
welcome to Etsy I'm never leaving Etsy's
Brooklyn headquarters is nine stories of
handmade having home to 800 employees
and check out the decor half of the
furniture in the 200,000 square foot
space was made by Etsy sellers welcome
to our labs this is just a dream boat of
craft supplies in order to de-stress I
can see these pom pom balls yeah some of
our employees will like to separate them
by color because it just gives them so
much satisfaction so today we are
focused on wedding gifts though because
it sees the destination for you to
discover the personalized thing that's
gonna stand out and really be for any
couple let's kick it off for the couple
who just moved into their new home or
once a refresh oh my gosh look at this
that's a custom illustration of a couple
this is a getter than towels a hundred
you cannot forget the fur babe
no you have the most important baby I
heard I'm gonna scoot it in that you
have a fur baby named Cali so we picked
this up and asked the seller to make you
a personalized illustration you're
welcome
Kali's like a member of family she's
here all the time so that's why health
is crying by the way for all these
goodies you can go to Etsy calm slash
gifts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]